ils ont la tête dans les étoiles dans ce
cas ce qu'a réalité virtuelle il se
balade dans le ciel de la nuit
précédente
on et comment la cosmonaute corner dans
l'espace
c'est assez impressionnant ça c'est
dérouleront ce planétarium est l'une des
animations proposées au sein de ce
village des sciences installé durant
trois jours à la commanderie à elancourt
c'est l'occasion de faire découvrir aux
gens un ciel qui voit plus en fait dans
les villes et puis c'est l'occasion
aussi pour les jeunes de leur donner
envie de faire la science depuis 12 ans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines rassemble laboratoire
entreprises universités associations
pour présenter la science et en large
public
chaque stand l'a finalement un double
discours à la fois pour un public
familial en médiation scientifique
on doit savoir s'adapter à tout public
donc faire une proposition qu'on dit
vulgariser pour les plus jeunes et plus
approfondies pour les adultes en famille
les visiteurs pouvaient notamment joué
les apprentis chimistes ou observer le
soleil à l'aide de cet appareil qui
filtrent la lumière mais à l'habitude de
voir où d'entendre les astronomes qui
parle des étoiles mais c'est vrai qu'on
a plus rarement l'occasion de voir la
note le soleil et et ouais les gens sont
assez curieux en général les tableau
périodique ont pris place dans la salle
des gardes les mesures était le thème
départemental de la fête de la science
on apprend plein de choses mamane au
grand âge
garnier des biens me contacter je
regarde aussi des pierres j'ai fait de
la science et j'ai tapé sur le clavier
je sais plus comment certaines mais
c'est intéressant
plus d'un millier de personnes ont
profité de ce village pour toucher la
science du bout des doigts